eventuell kennt ihr noch diese kinder
serie von früher mit diesem intro davon
meine damen und herren gibt es eine
online version ist dass dich
spitzenmäßig nein zocken ohne ende
fragen über fragen das pure
spielvergnügen
da geht doch die laune direkter hoch
spaß beiseite meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren wir spielen heute 1 2 oder 3
wir können hier bestimmte themenfelder
auswählen wie beispielsweise alle themen
natur umwelt menschen kultur essen
ich mag essen ich würde allerdings sagen
dass uns erst mal alle themen hier
auswählen und links wären wir dann einen
schwierigkeitsgrad aus damit nämlich
leicht mittel und schwer haben da würd
ich sagen neben der mittel
ihr könnt ihr gleich noch mal ein
bisschen eine schwerere gehen dann würde
ich jetzt auch ganz einfach mal auf
starten klicken und wir sehen schon was
ist der vorteil von aluminium beim
fahrradrahmen die zeit läuft jetzt ab
leichteres gewicht der härteres material
oder kommt ohne lackierung aus ich würde
sagen leichteres gewicht und meine
antwort ist natürlich richtig ich meine
freunde ich bin schon so häufig fahrrad
getan ich habe die tour de france 4000
mal gewonnen natürlich weiß ich so was
warum pinkeln kamele nur einen liter pro
tag wtf sich schwitzen den urin
größtenteils aus und feinden ihren
standort nicht zu verraten was hatte ich
mir sozusagen wasser zu sparen
oder freunde ich war 20 jahre meinem
leben war ich selber ein kamel deswegen
kann ich die frage natürlich auch simpel
war als zumal wie wird beim ball bzw
danke die kleine zielkugel genannt
cruiser oder esel ich würde sagen
keine ahnung ich meine ich habe so oft
den ball gespielt oder paaren theke dass
das ist doch klar dass ich das weiß was
ist das überhaupt schwebe fliegen haben
ähnliche farben und muster wie wespen
papageien oder zebras m schwebe fliegen
ich würde sagen wie wespen
freunde natürlich war ich auch eine
lange zeit in meinem leben selber als
schwebe fliege unterwegs sind den weiten
des meldet jetzt auch mal meine fresse
das ist doch schön aus die alle fragen
bisher richtig beantworten können lachen
ratten die viel lachen bevorzugen die
gesellschaft von ratten die gut kitzeln
können komisch aussehen die auch viel
die auch viel lachen freude
ich hab' ich habe bisher alles richtig
an der stelle muss ich allerdings auch
anmerken dass die meisten meiner freunde
selber ratten sind von daher war das
auch relativ easy für mich was leitet
glas besonders gut licht wärme oder
elektrischen strom
ich würde sagen glas leitet licht
mein
ja
warum blitzt es bei gewitter weil die
wolken
schneller fliegen als erlaubt ist weil
am boden stromleitungen explodieren oder
weil so die elektrizität aus den wolken
zum boden geleitet wird natürlich das
letzte freunde ihr wisst es ist auch
wieder richtig ich war selber lange zeit
als wolke unterwegs kurz nachdem ich die
schwebe fliege war was sind die briten
beim rund reißzähne zählen oder
tasthaare ich würde sagen ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung ich würde sagen
das ist die reißzähne weil meine damen
und herren ich war noch nie als hund
unterwegs deswegen konnte ich das nicht
wissen meine freunde sind ratten alter
toll wie soll ich dann wissen was die
wir prüfen wie heißt das wahrzeichen von
kopenhagen alter war ich in kopenhagen
oder was ariel kleine meerjungfrau oder
wassernixen ariel oder kommen
sag mir scheiße da war ich aber auch
noch nie unglaublich du bist ein
richtiger quiz profi deine
das ist doch nicht deren scheiß ernst so
sehen sieger aus tolle leistung das ist
ja super freunde allerdings würde ich
jetzt mal sagen dass wir hier essen
auswählen und wir lassen die
schwierigkeiten einfach auf mittels
klick auf start
warum ist es wichtig viele
unterschiedliche sachen zu essen weil
der körper verschiedene stoffe brauchen
essen sonst langweilig werden würde weil
von einer sorte lebensmittel nicht genug
vorhanden aber ich will auf jeden fall
sagen ein weil der körper verschiedene
stoffe braucht es natürlich logisch ich
für meinen teil es den ganztag nur pizza
aber auch pizza sind ja auch
verschiedene sachen drauf welche
nährstoffe sind für die
energielieferungen zuständig fett und
kohlenhydrate eiweiß und vitaminen für
die energielieferung ich würde sagen
fett und kohlenhydrate das ist auf jeden
fall richtig nämlich ein
ich würde so gut
falscher hase falschgeld kaninchen oder
hackbraten ich würde sagen falschgeld
oder ein kaninchen
braten was passiert wenn wir mehr kohlen
tradition zu nehmen als wir brauchen sie
bleiben solange und verlaute magen
bisher wieder energie brauchen sie
werden unverdaut wieder ausgeschieden
werden eingelagert wir nehmen zu das ist
das was ich tun sollte und das auch
richtig aber ich bin in wien kaká
was ist eine flotte lotte ich würde
sagen das ist eine biene oder eine
tänzerin
und ein küchengerät
und dann ist helferin ich sage aber es
ist eine biene warum können die
mineralstoffe aus mineralwasser
besonders gut aufgenommen werden weil
sie durch wasser aufquellen besser
erkannt weil man es nicht haut sondern
sind schon im wasser gelöst sind so kann
schade ich hatte nicht mal zeit mir das
durchzulesen thailand ist weltweit der
größte markt die durian frucht wie sie
in vielen verboten weil die stinkt wie
save safe sie wieder stinkfrucht
bezeichnet habe ich mit maximal video zu
gemacht und es ist richtig stinkfrucht
was wurde in einem henkelmann
transportiert in einem henkelmann wird
glaube ich essen transportiert weil dass
er das ist wo man das hochheben kann und
das ist natürlich richtig freunde weil
ich selber immer von meinen ganzen
butlern essen in dem henkelmann bekomme
unglaublich du bist ein richtiger quiz
profi deine urkunde machen schauen
gut gemacht beim nächsten mal wird es
noch besser witze mich verarschen alter
an der stelle wo ich das video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
auch gerne mal einen like da habt ihr
bock auf mehr solcher ein zwei oder drei
küsse es weil ich meiner gab es ja
unglaublich viele verschiedene
kategorien denn je mehr davon sehen
wollte meine damen und herren dann lass
mal 50.000 likes das ist eine sehr große
anzahl aber dadurch sehe ich dass ihr
das geil findet und dass ihr das wollt
und sonst meine damen und herren sind
wir jetzt an anderer stelle angekommen
wo er nicht ich jetzt etwas sagen werde
sondern dass übernimmt jetzt der liebe
anton und wann kannst du mal kurz sagen